today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video we've
been desperately waiting for leadership
from Donald Trump as the country has
fallen into further disrepair and chaos
combining a hundred year pandemic with
more civil unrest than we've seen in a
very long time and as I told you
yesterday Donald Trump spent the weekend
tweeting from his bunker he emerged
yesterday to the Rose Garden of the
White House and instead of being
conciliatory instead of bringing down
tensions instead of doing something that
we could call sensible leadership Donald
Trump went full authoritarian saying
that when governors don't handle
protests the way Trump wants them to
handle them
he will activate and deploy the military
to States for law enforcement purposes
here is Trump himself making the
statement yesterday that is why I am
taking immediate presidential action to
stop the violence and restore security
and safety in America
I am mobilizing all available federal
resources civilian and military to stop
the rioting and looting to end the
destruction and arson and to protect the
rights of law-abiding Americans
including your second Amendment rights
therefore the following measures are
going into effect immediately first we
are ending the riots and lawlessness
that has spread throughout our country
we will end it now today I have strongly
recommended to every governor to deploy
the National Guard in sufficient numbers
that we dominate the streets mayors and
governors must establish an overwhelming
law enforcement presence until the
violence has been quelled if a city or
state refuses to take the actions that
are necessary
to defend the life and property of their
residents then I will deploy the United
States military and quickly solve the
problem for them so there are about a
hundred different things to talk about
here but don't kid yourselves this is
not a rehearsal this is the
authoritarian nightmare that we've been
worried about with Donald Trump for
three and a half years that has been
slowly building and escalating and first
of all just like aside from the legality
of this which I want to talk about
there's a lot of misinformation
spreading about it this is the opposite
of what we need we have peak unrest in
this country started because law
enforcement used too much force in
Minneapolis on George Floyd so Donald
Trump comes out and says hey governor's
you need to up the force used by law
enforcement or I will up it for you by
deploying the military to your states it
is inconceivable this is the worst
possible thing that you could do second
is this legal now there's a lot of
misinformation and disinformation being
spread about this so let's actually go
through each step and I'll tell you
where a lot of people are getting either
confused or they're deliberately
spreading this information so in the
United States we have something called
the Posse Comitatus Act or Comitatus Act
I don't know how it's pronounced it
dates back to 1878 and what this Act
does is it says the federal government
can't use federal military personnel to
enforce domestic policies that's exactly
what Donald Trump wants to do Donald
Trump wants to send federal military
personnel to States to enforce local law
enforcement policy understand that when
a state deploys their National Guard
that does not violate this law a lot of
people don't necessarily make the
distinction between National Guard's our
state units they're administered by the
state governor and we've had during
coronavirus we've even had National
Guard deployed by governor's to help
with you know traffic or test sites or
whatever else the case may be perfect
illegal doesn't violate the Posse
Comitatus Act Donald Trump here is
talking about deploying federal military
assets to States to enforce a domestic
law and that is exactly what is
prohibited by the Posse Comitatus Act so
that's step one now step two can trump
get around that and the answer is yes he
can
and this is where a lot of the
disinformation is spreading so pay
particular attention to the details here
which are that there is something called
the insurrection act the insurrection
Act can be invoked by a president and it
would give them the authority to legally
deploy federal military within the
United States if it is in a situation
where you need to suppress civil
disorder insurrection or rebellion now
this is where the misinformation is
starting you've got legal experts going
on TV and saying listen guys the Posse
Comitatus Act is not in play because
Donald Trump is planning to or is going
to or can invoke the insurrection act at
any time this has been done a lot and
it's really not a big deal and usually
they'll say listen just 28 years ago it
was used in 1992 in Los Angeles during
the Rodney King riots the president
invoked the insurrection act in order to
deploy the military to California but
what they're not telling you is that the
usage of the insurrection act in 1992
was the president using it at the
request of the California Governor Pete
Wilson so what we have here is Trump
threatening governor's saying hey guys
if you don't enforce what I believe
needs to be enforced I am going to fight
you go against you by using the
insurrection act to deploy the federal
military to your state's 1992 was
governor Pete Wilson saying hey let's
invoke the insurrection act because
things are out of control and that was
done with executive order one to 8:04 by
a President George HW Bush of course 92
an election year drove Bill Clinton
winning
November of 92 being sworn in in January
of 1993 what we are talking about here
is a president unilaterally imposing the
insurrection act on governor's so we
can't look at 1992 because in 1992 Pete
Wilson said we need to do this this is
Trump saying not I'm working with the
governor's to do this it's I'm going to
punish the governor's I'm gonna fight
the governor's with the insurrection act
the insurrection Act of 1807 has not
been used unilaterally in 57 years and
it has never been used in the way Trump
wants to use it which is essentially to
override local discretion regarding how
to manage the unrest that is currently
going on when you look at some of the
previous uses of the insurrection act
against a governor's wishes they were
done against racism
okay so understand the insanity of what
we have what we look at in the past
would be Lincoln in 1861 right we had
the civil war to fight slavery
Eisenhower and 57 in Arkansas to fight
state racism Kennedy in 1962 in
Mississippi Kennedy in 1963 in Alabama
so when in the past a president has
invoked the insurrection act not in in
concert with governor's but against them
it has been to fight racism we could not
be further from that in what Donald
Trump is trying to do here now if Trump
tries to do it it could become a legal
fight but this is all part of the
continued distract the thon I tweeted
last night that Trump's strategy here on
the protest ironically this is this is
not like a Russia thing but ironically
Trump's strategy is CCCP and I'll tell
you what that stands for confused about
what's actually happening in our country
that's number one number two conflate
protesters versus looters versus rioters
versus insiders criticize everybody
right so governors Democrats protesters
and then lastly CCC P the P is pander
pander to his Trump is base much of
which loves authoritarianism also
pandering to his base by going and stage
a propaganda picture of himself holding
a Bible in front of st. John's Cathedral
after yesterday's Rose Garden statement
and that's what I want to talk about
next so we are in a full dystopia at
this point in time yesterday I already
told you Donald Trump went to the Rose
Garden
he gave an authoritarian nightmare of a
speech where he says he will fight
governor's by deploying the military to
enforce the law in their states the
legal fight is Posse Comitatus Act
versus insurrection act we've already
talked about that certainly at its face
the idea that we need to fight protests
about law enforcement using too much
force by scaling up the amount of force
used by law enforcement that's crazy
we've already talked about that but then
we get into the propaganda of this
Donald Trump had protesters tear gassed
and dispersed with horses to clear the
way for Donald Trump to walk to st.
John's Church in Washington DC and be
photographed holding up a Bible he was
asked mr. president is that your Bible
and he said it is a Bible of course it's
not Trump's Bible Trump is not religious
this is merely pandering in front of the
church this was done in a completely
just sickening obvious brazen attempt to
propagandize but in order to get over
there here is video of the protesters
and here you will hear the bangs going
off you will see the gas start to rise
hey he takes the propaganda seriously
for sure here are members of the press
being shooed away as Donald Trump walks
over to the Cathedral and then hears an
overhead view of the entire crowd being
aggressively dispersed including with
tear gas because the leader Trump must
get to the church to hold someone's
Bible bringing out the horses you're
gonna hear some of the flashbangs at the
start of this video
and so then here is Donald Trump calling
over his press secretary and a couple of
others and standing there and sort of it
at some point Trump says okay the
propaganda event is over and this is one
of the most Awkward video clips I've
seen in a long time
thank you very much
the greatest country in the world thank
you very much everybody
they keep it nice and safe so everybody
there in that photo-op people who should
be people who should be unemployed come
January if we do our job in November now
by the way just one other thing from
earlier here was Trump's Rose Garden
statement just minutes before walking
over to st. John's having protesters to
your Gaston dispersed with horses you
can hear explosions going on in the
background while Trump is speaking he
will not have died in vain but we cannot
allow the righteous cries of peaceful
protesters to be drowned out by an angry
mob the biggest victims of the riot that
is not thunder you are hearing my
friends those are flash bangs going off
to disperse protesters in advance of
Trump walking over to st. John's
Cathedral this is where we are it's
incredible how far we have fallen since
that horrible day November of 2016 and
I've been you know I've been talking
about hyper normalization I've been
talking about desensitization it happens
a little bit at a time but now when you
go back and think of that day when
Donald Trump was inaugurated we have
fallen so so far now if you need a
reminder of how not religious Trump is
if you needed a reminder of how the
Bible and the church are just props for
the president remember this video for
the camp from the campaign where Donald
Trump making it abundantly clear he
doesn't know a damn thing about the
Bible he doesn't care about the Bible
you mentioned the Bible you've been
talking about how it's your favorite
book and you said I think last night in
Iowa some people are surprised that you
say that I'm wondering what one or two
of your most favored Bible verses are I
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when I
talk about the Bible is very personal so
I don't want to get into really I don't
want to get into it means a lot to you
that you think about ersite the Bible
means a lot to me but I don't want to
get into specifics even decide a verse
you know like I don't want to do
Testament Geyer New Testament probably
equal I think it's just an incredible
the whole Bible is an incredible I joke
very much so they always hold up the art
of the deal I say my second favorite
book of all time but I just think the
Bible is just something very special
this has to stop this has to stop for
our sake it has to stop for the world's
sake it has to stop for our futures sake
Trump doesn't even attend church it's
not even his Bible aggressively and
violently dispersing peaceful protestors
with horses and flashbangs and tear gas
so that he could hold up someone's Bible
and take advantage of just a disgusting
I mean this is this is like Soviet style
North Korea style propaganda that Donald
Trump is brazenly crafting in front of
our very eyes and we have to end it we
have to end it let me know your thoughts
about all of this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman thrilled to see more and more
folks listening to the daily audio
podcast of the show if you watch on
YouTube you may not know that you can go
on iTunes or stitcher or Google Play
podcast whatever you want and get our
daily audio podcast do it it's a great
way to consume the show in addition to
the YouTube clips let me know your
thoughts about this propaganda on
Twitter at each Ackman and we'll be
right back
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David to get your
first shipment of blue to completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com all right we have so much to
get through today that i will take no
more than 15 seconds to say thanks to
david Samuels and Nicolas Guzman today's
new David Pakman show members of the day
and a big thank you to Michael Mont
Inara who is today's long-term
sustaining member he's been a member for
five years support the show at join
pakman.com with a membership okay we
have leaked audio of an absolute madman
rant by the president this happened
during a call that donald trump had
yesterday with governors from around the
country the calls were about the
protests the calls were in advance of
donald trump going out into the rose
garden and saying if you don't scale up
force i will do it for you by sending
the military to your states these are
simply put the rantings of an agitated
lunatic authoritarian who sounds very
desperate who sounds very scared and
realizes he is quickly losing control
that he probably never even really had
let's take a listen to it the context is
totally impotent trump who was tweeting
insults and threats all weekend from the
white house while adults actually tried
to figure out what to do so first of all
donald trump says here i guess that the
minneapolis police so there is trump
brown
about when the police became more
militarized they started carving through
crowds of protesters like butter just
disgusting language and for Trump this
is all sport it's all visual it's what
is Fox News showing when Trump turns on
the channel let's continue it only gets
worse from here unfortunately
so here's Donald Trump again making the
case that forces police forces need to
be militarized this is part of the
problem on in the United States
understand that we have a situation here
where we have protests and unrest which
were catalyzed by police using too much
force and killing George Floyd and Trump
is demanding that law enforcement use
even more force it's it could not
possibly be more backwards then here is
Trump again continuing in this leaked
audio of a call with governor's using
the language of the domination of
protesters take a look
again the police for police forces must
toughen up
we'll send soldiers you have to dominate
the protesters Trump reportedly angry
throughout the entire call Trump said
leaders should be seeking retribution
this is the language of a mob boss this
is not the language of a President of
the United States faced with unrest the
likes of which we've not seen for a long
time
Trump told governor's you don't have to
be too careful in other words don't be
too careful do the opposite of being
careful Trump does not know how to lead
he simply does not have listened he
doesn't have the cognitive capacity to
deal with the complexity of this
situation we have to concede that and
his view is this over-aggressive view of
let's dominate the protesters he seems
afraid not literally of the protesters
but of what this could do to his
presidency but it is just not within him
to lead he doesn't have any tools as I
said yesterday and a lot of people wrote
to me and said David that this felt like
the the right metaphor or analogy and I
didn't come up with it if you only have
a hammer everything looks like a nail
and that is exactly the situation we
have Trump has very few tools and he he
doesn't have a velvet glove the way he
himself once analogized he has a couple
of different size hammers and so
everything looks like a nail to him his
his tools are shaming people insulting
people making threats that's what he's
doing here even though it's absolutely
the last thing that we need so we have
to realize at this point many things but
I'll focus on two important realizations
that we need to come to and I know many
of you have probably come to these
realizations already number one we
aren't going to get anything but more of
this from Donald Trump period no matter
the circumstances no matter what is
necessary no matter what is called for
these are his routines and this is all
he can really do staged photo ops at the
church that we talked about earlier the
military deployments saying governor's
you you better get it together you guys
are jerks or incompetent or would have
else that's number but that's all we are
going to get from Trump number two there
is a possibility that Trump actually
sees more chaos as good for him
especially if he can frame his frame it
as this is the merely the left doing bad
things which they've started to do
yesterday yesterday I covered live
Trump's press secretary Kelly mcenany
did a press briefing and she must have
talked about antiva you know what a
dozen times two dozen times and this is
a calculated strategy they talk about
antifa to dismiss and disqualify the
overwhelmingly peaceful protesters the
actual issues that launched these
protests now I don't know if it will
work this may be a miscalculation by
Donald Trump or it may work if the virus
continues if the chaos continues if the
country continues to see no leadership
from Donald Trump and meanwhile Joe
Biden keeps meeting with protesters and
staking out a position on police
treatment of minorities that addresses
the systemic problems this doesn't mean
Joe Biden is a hero this means nothing
other than on this issue right now right
you can talk about Biden in 94 right now
Joe Biden is showing more leadership and
understanding of this issue than is
Donald Trump I don't know that Trump is
going to come away from this unscathed
or with a with an increased approval
rating because it doesn't look like he's
doing anything right now there's a new
national poll out from NBC from ABC from
over the weekend which has Joe Biden at
+10 points nationally against Donald
Trump this is an unconscionable number
this is on the high end polls are
generally showing Biden leading by
between 4 and 11 nationally so certainly
10 is on the high end but what is it
that will come from what Trump is doing
that will close the gap with Biden
whether you believe the gap is 4 or 10
or 7 what is it that Trump is doing that
will close the gap it's hard to imagine
his supporters will be with him no
matter what but consider the backwards
nature of Trump's reaction and this is
what I keep going back to the protests
were started by the brutal handling of a
black man by Minnesota police so
what is Trump do he says you governor's
need to be more aggressive and I will
send federal military to be more
aggressive if you don't do it I don't
know that this will work I hope that it
doesn't work because it's absolutely
horrifying let's talk a little bit about
the fact that we still have a
hundred-year global pandemic going on in
the United States and many states are
improving while many states are
worsening in terms of the spread we will
see what effect the protests have on
spread of the virus it'll take about 10
days to know for sure
but I wanted to let you guys know
something that maybe won't will not
surprise some of you which is that dr.
Anthony Fauci
has now confirmed that Donald Trump no
longer speaks to him very much and that
he doesn't speak to really any of the
doctors on the coronavirus task force
now why wouldn't this surprise you well
if you know Trump it wouldn't surprise
you but five or six weeks ago I came to
you and I said Donald Trump is now
transitioning to we are no longer going
to talk about coronavirus as a medical
event we are no longer talking about
coronavirus as a medical problem we're
going to shift to we being Trump we're
going to shift to round tables with CEOs
about how much we're reopening and how
many loans we've dispersed and yada yada
yada dr. Anthony Fauci on the
coronavirus Task Force is the top
infectious disease doctor in the United
States and we as a country started to
see less and less of him weeks ago
doctor foul Qi now has done a number of
interviews recently and in one interview
with stat news said something incredibly
revealing but not altogether shocking
doctor foul she was asked does the
president talk to you about the vaccine
work often and foul cheese answer was no
we used to have task force meetings
every single day including Saturday and
Sunday and about 75% of the time after
the task force meeting we would meet
with the president so I was meeting with
him four times a week back a month or so
ago but as you probably noticed that the
task force meetings have not occurred as
often lately and certainly my meetings
with the president have been
dramatically decreased now there are
going to be right-wingers and Trump
assay this makes sense this makes sense
the
oblem is going away the problem being
coronavirus so of course you have fewer
meetings the problem is that that's not
based in reality look at the trend lines
in the United States cases and deaths
have slowly declined over a 10 week
period but we are often still finding
20,000 22,000 new cases in a single day
in terms of deaths
fortunately the trendline is down but we
still regularly have 1500 deaths in a
single day from coronavirus so nothing
is over this may end up merely being a
warm-up for wave 2 in the fall which
could be even worse it could be not as
bad we don't know we might not really
even have a break between the two waves
and indeed it seemed like the breaking
point for Donald Trump was that just
disastrous shameful press briefing in
April where Trump wondered aloud about
injecting bleach and rubbing alcohol
into the body and the coronavirus press
briefings were already starting to wane
then and now it's over and doctor foul
Chi has barely any contact with Donald
Trump now there's some aspect of if I
don't look at it if I don't talk about
it it doesn't exist it's like a hear no
evil see no evil sort of thing there
this is kind of a weird direction to go
but there's something called object
permanence and child development people
will know about this already and this is
a big milestone for little kids as
babies develop there's a phase where if
you take a ball and you hide it the baby
doesn't know that the ball continues to
exist even if you've hidden it behind
your back and at some point I can't
believe this is what how we're analyzing
a president at some point in child
development developing children realize
even if I can no longer see the ball the
ball still exists they can hold the idea
of the ball in their mind and they
continue to understand that just because
you don't see the ball doesn't mean it
has disappeared from existence Trump's
strategy is like that of a baby pre
development of object permanence I won't
talk about it I won't look at it it's
like it doesn't exist and Trump had this
idea pretty early on
remember with testing Trump knew early
on if
we do more testing we're gonna find more
cases let's keep our case numbers low by
not doing a lot of testing that of
course backfired so then we get to a
separate question which is does Trump
even believe experts who come to him
with information that he admittedly
doesn't even want to be given not really
Donald Trump believes he knows more than
his generals and his doctors and more
than anybody so the benefit to meeting
with the experts is limited by the fact
that Trump thinks he knows more than
them anyway but regardless dr. Anthony
Fauci no longer getting much face time
with Donald Trump not a big surprise I
would love it if doctor foul Chi did
regular briefings himself I wouldn't
even be opposed to the CDC being part of
them like dr. Redfield I know he's kind
of a trump tool but without Trump
hovering in the background hinge forward
at the hips and swiveling as he often
does during during the the briefings up
I think doctor foul Chi and dr. Redfield
together could give us a lot of really
valuable information Burks you know
remains a question mark in terms of her
just blind loyalty to Donald Trump but
it would be great to do it like other
countries do it
get the politicians out let's get a
briefing from medical experts period
we're not getting that either
unfortunately follow the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show
for continued coverage of all of today's
stories and while you are there follow
my personal Instagram not very political
many elements of recreation and
gardening on my personal Instagram may
be a good respite from consistently
horrible news that we are facing today I
am David Pakman
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show it's great to
welcome to the program today Jonathan
Hebert who's the author of the new book
critical thinking from MIT press also
the guy behind logic check dotnet a
website that checks not just the facts
but also the reasoning behind the news
of the day it's so great to have you on
jonathan great to be on david so what
what is the sort of origin of critical
thinking as a discipline does it come
from some of those philosophers that
many of us were introduced to an in
freshman year of college
is it older than that well it definitely
draws on those ancient disciplines
certainly philosophy particularly
Western philosophy the work of Aristotle
but also more modern disciplines such as
science particularly some of the early
science that was a discourse between you
know philosophers and sort of proto
scientists psychology more recently and
then most recently cognitive science so
actually critical thinking itself the
concept that there's a form of thinking
unique enough to be all called critical
distinct from intelligence and wisdom is
actually a 20th century concept the some
of the so we've seen you know what a
media literacy class can look like
teaching one to critically analyze media
messages critical thinking epistemology
there's a lot of material on the
Internet is the reason that a lot of
this material is
necessary that these are not concepts
that we intuitively learn in the sense
that at some point you know a baby
realizes that the circle is not going to
fit into the rectangular pair that you
know triangular peg or whatever and it's
an intuitive lesson are the critical
thinking skills that you espouse and
talked about in the book are they not
something humans intuitively pick up
well they're definitely not our
intuitions actually need to be
disciplined which is why you need struck
to structure your thinking in order to
reason I think you know science is a
good example where people have not
historically always thought
scientifically that was something that
was constructed and over centuries
really the discipline of thinking
scientifically sort of developed into a
norm I think critical thinking is much
more broad than that it's something that
you could apply not just a science but
to every subject but it's not something
that comes intuitively nor is it taught
I mean it used to be you know going back
to Roman times logic rhetoric those were
the cornerstones of the educational
curriculum right through modernity
but in modern times of course have many
more things to learn modern science
history cultures language which is great
but I think that meant that logic
rhetoric some of the critical thinking
kind of core foundational skills have
been crowded out in favor of new
knowledge and I think that's one of the
reasons we both lack the intuition but
we're not taught this in schools are we
currently sort of at a bad moment when
it comes to critical thinking skills in
the population at large I know we've
been tracking an - anti intellectual
movements certainly for a couple hundred
years with a pretty significant degree
of specificity but is there some sort of
like peak that we are now experiencing
or dearth maybe is the right word you
know I think there's there's not been
some Golden Age where everybody thought
critically and we've sort of fallen off
since then I mean this has always been a
set of skills that some people take on
some people don't some people
maybe more naturally inclined towards
thinking reasonably than others or you
have you know what's very typical is
people will think critically about
subjects like their jobs right they'll
make decisions about you know your
carpenter how to cut a piece of wood
your computer program or you can think
very logically when you're writing code
but we will not apply it to things like
political decisions whom to vote for or
even sort of interpersonal decisions so
I think probably what makes this period
more nerve-wracking is that there are
all kinds of ways to support thinking
poorly you know critical thinking is
kind of thinking well there are less
productive ways of thinking you can
believe whatever you already believe you
know confirmation bias you could believe
whatever you're told
right just believe authority figures and
I think now that we have a new media
landscape particularly with social media
that allows us to isolate ourselves into
bubbles where we don't really even have
to listen to anybody we disagree with I
think a lot of the sort of toxic
politics and miscommunication we have is
a result of you know not so much that
people aren't internalizing the rules of
critical thinking I think just there's
there's more sources of bad premises I
guess around is the what is the
mechanism that is most effective at
disarming ones critical thinking
faculties I mean you sort of alluded in
a way personal life's things and
political things as opposed to how a
woodworker may best cut a piece of wood
is it sort of having a personal stake
which which blinds us maybe to applying
the same type of critical thinking we
otherwise would I think that that
there's you know critical thinking
skills you know you you had your YouTube
channel where you cover many of the
logical skills that are vital to
critical thinking that's what's covered
a lot of critical thinking courses you
might take in college and there's a lot
of material on the internet on logic and
fallacies and those sorts of things so
that's the sort of knowledge you need
but then you need the skills to use that
knowledge in other words if we're
talking about logic for this example you
need to
put those skills to use but put
illogical principles to use a lot in
lots of situations in your work in your
school in your life yeah and you need to
sort of favor thinking reasonably
thinking logically over other forms of
reasoning such as just believing what
you've already believed but then there's
a whole group of dispositions you know
you have to want to apply logic to
things that might make you uncomfortable
like examining your own beliefs for
example and I think that without all
three pieces without the knowledge the
skills and the dispositions you can't
really be think of yourself as a
critical thinker so I'd say situations
where people you know are very skilled
thinkers in certain parts of their life
but turn off reason when it comes up to
other factors that's a form of sort of
not thinking critically in terms of not
exercising proper critical thinking
dispositions yeah so you can't teach
someone to want to examine their own
beliefs right I mean so it's you could
maybe encourage someone but it's not a
teachable skill in the same way that
identifying fallacies would be I think
it's a teachable accept that you can
learn about the sort of flaws in the
human makeup that are non cognitive
right some of them are you know we can
be led by emotions or instincts right
those can overwhelm reason and also you
know there's cognitive biases there's
been a whole cottage industry of people
writing about confirmation bias and
anchoring bias and all these various
sort of you know flaws and our reasoning
so I think you can learn about the human
minds makeup and understand that we are
all susceptible to flawed thinking and
therefore we shouldn't assume we're
always right but I think in terms of
dispositions that would follow the
category of kind of morals education you
know that these are intellectual virtues
right open-mindedness faith and reason
intellectual humility and I think you
can learn those the same way you learn
other moral principles by example
example if you're your household if
these are intellectual virtues are
practiced then you'll tend to
likely internalize them if you live in a
household with dogmatic politics for
example or a place where fundamental
beliefs are never questioned then you
will learn that you will learn that
right you'll learn not to question
beliefs so I think they can be learned
it's sort of like behaviors you know any
sort of ethical behavior you learn them
over time when it comes to to make this
really concrete given the subject matter
of this program when it comes to
political messages and material that we
get through corporate media and and mass
media what would you say are the one or
two sort of lowest hanging fruit in
terms of the principles that if more
frequently applied would lead to far
more informed people so like one that I
might look at would be just
understanding correlation versus
causation right with coronavirus people
who get really sick tend to have lower
vitamin D levels is that a causation or
is that a correlation explained by
something else
the economy did well after something
happened with taxes did it do well
because of that or are they both impact
right so that would be one that I would
maybe consider but I'm curious what you
would think about is the the most
important lowest hanging fruit that
would most help consumers of political
news well I think you know correlation
versus causation you know much like the
difference between deductive and
inductive reasoning and many of the
topics that kind of going to be in
critical thinker those are all vital and
I think the good news is one can learn
what they are and how to use them
relatively quickly I mean I think your
videos were three to five minutes on
each of these topics I did a program
called critical voter that sort of
taught much of the same material and I
was surprised how easy it is to learn
those things so I think certainly you
know the three things I would recommend
is one you know learn those things
because it doesn't take that much time
but I think you know if you want the
low-hanging fruit the things to do would
be one to practice them to use them as
much as possible critical thinking is
really a skill it's kind of like playing
the piano or being good at a sport right
the more you do
the better you get there's one
researcher who thinks critical thinking
is like you know a sport or an
instrument it takes 10,000 hours to get
really good at it so I'd say because the
knowledge and the techniques are
relatively easy to pick up it's just a
question of how much you dedicate to
practicing them and then I guess the
other piece I'd say the lowest hanging
fruit even though might be the most
difficult is shared ability you know
being charitable to opinions especially
those you don't agree with I think so
you did last week you refer to steel
Manning an argument which as opposed to
straw Manning an argument naturally a
reflection of the principle of charity
right you should try to address the
strongest version of an opponent's
argument rather than attacking one flaw
in it or coming up with a weak version
or a parody and that's relatively easy
to do when it's your own arguments
you're looking to sort of strengthen I
think the hardest part is to treat
opposing arguments treating arguments
from people who you fundamentally
disagree with in a charitable fashion
but I think a lot of intellectual
virtues kind of derive from that spirit
of charity in the limited time we have
is there one specific example that
you've seen be one of the most difficult
beliefs or areas of subject matter for
people to really think critically about
well the two big ones obviously politics
and religion right because these at both
are fundamentally about our identity and
I think certainly is religion sort of
fades as a foundation of identity our
sort of political identities take on
many qualities that were once sort of
you see and religious-based conflicts
you know kind of over the level of
heated nests so I would say you know the
understanding that any argument based on
somebody's identity is going to be have
to treat and be treated very sensitively
right because nobody ever changed their
mind about a belief fundamental or
identity because they lost in arguments
right nobody changed their mind because
they lost my argument on Twitter for
example but but even sort of lost you
know some more civilized argument right
that
crack the ice that might sort of get you
thinking oh maybe there's some things I
don't know or maybe some of the things I
believe I should question but changing
your mind changing beliefs about
something that's very very personal to
you is something that leaves you very
vulnerable so I think if if we want to
change the minds of others which
obviously you know your program and and
other media programs like it are looking
to do you should sort of do what you can
to empathize with those who disagree
with try to get into their heads try to
understand what they're thinking and an
exercise I often challenge people on is
you know think about what arguments
would get you to change your mind about
something that you strongly believe in
and that'll get you to sort of
understand the difficulty of such a
situation and once you could appreciate
it then I think you might be in a better
position to address opponents or address
people who you disagree with in a more
empathetic and anything ultimately
potentially more successful way the book
is critical thinking we've been speaking
with the author Jonathan Hebert who's
worth you can also find at logic check
dotnet Jonathan really appreciate your
time and it's been a pleasure having you
oh thank you and thanks for all your
work
well the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay this is not the most important
aspect of the current situation that
we're in I understand that but I do
believe it's worth mentioning because
there's a very important media component
to what is going on in our country right
now not only with the protests and the
unrest and George Floyd but also with
coronavirus this happened early with
coronavirus and it is now happening with
all content related to George Floyd
protests police brutality and Tifa
and even Trump's comments about these
things YouTube and Facebook have
completely demonetised all of this
content if you talk about one of the
most important issues facing our country
right now YouTube and Facebook will de
monetize your videos now I want to be
really clear this is not me crying
censorship this is not me saying YouTube
and Facebook or doing something illegal
this is me explaining to you how they
are making the wrong decision and this
is how the soft suppression using D
monetization of newsworthy independent
reporting happens now I can talk about
the fact that our country is burning
down as relations between citizens and
law enforcement completely break down I
can talk about the fact that we have
three officers still not charged who
were standing there watching a fourth
officer killed George Floyd I can talk
about how our president is failing to
lead and egging on police violence but
we won't make any money from that and
I'll have to figure out a different way
to pay staff and to do everything that
we do and believe me I'm going to keep
talking about it because you need to
know what's going on and we can't leave
it simply to corporatist voices to tell
you what it is that's going on but this
is very ugly it is tragic in fact
yesterday we did a ton of coverage of
course of George Floyd the protests and
tangentially related topics all
demonetized on both YouTube and Facebook
check this out this is how important
reporting gets suppressed so okay
protests erupt and society breaks down
that
a 15-minute segment I got a lot of
compliments about it spent all weekend
researching how I wanted to approach
this demonetized yellow dollar sign as
you can see on youtube also demonetised
on Facebook
Trump threatening protestors with dogs
this is a scandal
sorry demonetised on YouTube and
Facebook
police victims or oppressors hugely
important story nearly 10 minutes about
how should police departments and
officers deal with what's going on is
staying silent making one a part of the
problem this is a paramount issue
demonetised Trump says he will designate
an Tifa a terrorist group this is a
president misusing the State
Department's foreign terrorist
organization list to suppress American
citizens due process and First Amendment
it's a distraction from the real issues
it's a totalitarian scandal sorry David
demonetized
and then of course our full our show the
full hour show which contains these
stories also
demonetized what are we doing guys what
is the point of all this what's the
point of putting in the work and you
know it's a really clever and great way
to virtue signal to say we want people
dealing with important issues we don't
want clickbait we don't want low-effort
content well we spent all weekend
researching this stuff violent and
nonviolent protests destruction of
property as a form of protest
historically the six or seven different
components to the protest I mean you
know we're talking about a ton of staff
time and it's just like yeah yeah sorry
our country's burning but if you want to
monetize what about a Kardashian lying
about being a billionaire maybe talk
about that if you want to monetize
YouTube says we want to be part of the
solutions conversations we want to
support creators Facebook supposedly the
same thing but if you even tangentially
touch the biggest news story along with
coronavirus then no ads are going to
play you might remember this happened at
the start of coronavirus as well we were
early on coronavirus we were covering it
early despite not only the fact that a
lot
people thought it was overblown then but
despite the monetization and we kept
doing it after like a month YouTube
realized this coronavirus thing might go
on for a while we can'tjust demonetised
and they started to monetize it this is
how you nudge channels so that they'll
opt to cover you know some BS and more
and more of the coverage of what's going
on in this country the social unrest
ends up being corporate media and
independent channels get pushed away
from it so we're not backing off today's
show also I mean the entire show is
likely to be d monetized maybe there's a
one or two stories that won't be we are
not going to back off talking about it
we have a crisis the crisis is that
Trump's leadership has failed we have
major conflict when it comes to law
enforcement all of it needs to be
discussed but this is how YouTube and
Facebook are dealing with it so know
that if you want if you're able you can
support our work directly only about
half of 1% of our audience has
memberships but you can grab a
membership at join pakman.com if we can
get from half of one percent to one
percent of our audience supporting us
it's game over right I mean none of this
stuff matters none of the D monetization
matters so consider grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com you can
get a 66% discount with the code this is
20/20 don't feel obligated to use the
discount don't feel obligated to get a
membership at all we're gonna continue
covering this stuff because it matters
and it is it is once again tragic that
this is how some of the major platforms
where we get you know millions and tens
of millions of views a month between
YouTube and Facebook that this is the
approach that they are taking it's sick
we can fight it and you know even if you
don't support me support some other show
if you think of some other show is doing
better coverage of this by all means
support them but we we have to make sure
that independent voices don't get sort
of softly nudged away from talking about
this stuff because then it leaves just
the corporate media outlets talking
about it we can't allow that to happen
here is something I want to address that
has come up quite a bit because of what
we're experiencing right now since the
killing of George Floyd by Derek shavon
there are people on the left and on the
right who will sometimes try to tout
their non racist bona fides by using
some version of the phrase I don't see
color now different people will use that
phrase to mean different things there
are people who will sometimes use the
phrase I don't see color when they're
called out about some policy that will
like disproportionately affect
minorities they'll say I don't see color
I'm just talking about policy sometimes
you will see people say I don't see
color in the sense that they say they
are colorblind in their political views
this is a very dumb phrase and I would
suggest that it not be used anymore and
I want to be clear that I understand
what people often mean when they say I
don't see color and I'm gonna give you a
better way to talk about it that that's
more credible because I don't see color
doesn't really make any sense because
all of the science tells us we very much
see color we just do doesn't mean we're
racist that doesn't mean we discriminate
but the instant that we meet people
whether it's Western individuals in
developed countries or remote tribes in
the Amazon or the Australian outback
we almost instantly are assessing and
assimilating what we believe to be the
gender of the person we are talking to
the age of the person we are talking to
and the race of the person we are
talking to to the extent that you can
discern that from looking at them the
instant I walk up to a cashier at my
grocery store I am instantly making an
assessment of I'm speaking to a roughly
thirty year-old Hispanic female for
example we all see color and we all are
instantly assessing it because it's just
part of being human and living in a
society is there any situation in which
someone could come up to you and say hey
remember the gardener that came to the
house last week do you remember if they
were male or female no I have no
recollection of it of course you do of
course you do was the nurse that did
your kovat test was it like a
twenty-something nurse or was it like a
60 something-year-old nurse
I have no I don't remember was your bank
teller yesterday white black Asian or
Hispanic I have no idea we all know it
unless you know barring some kind of
memory or cognitive issue so when I hear
people say things like I don't see color
in my interactions with the world people
are just people give me a break
you do you see gender and you see age
and we are immediately assessing race
and color as well we all see each other
we recognize how someone might look
similar or different from us and that is
okay what might actually be accurate to
say and where I think the focus should
be is I don't judge people on the basis
of their appearance which includes race
that might be accurate now a lot of us
still have implicit and preconceived
notions about people on the basis of
these characteristics in many cases
they're relatively benign and that's
fine sometimes they are discriminatory
but I actually want to go even further
imagine that it were true we we don't
notice people's race we really don't see
color when if that were to be the case
it would immediately dismiss the reality
that there are racial and Justices even
today in society if I didn't see color
if someone said to me hey can you snap
your fingers and you could you could
snap your fingers and become black right
now in society would you want to do it
if I didn't see color IVA I'd have no
way to answer that question now of
course I see color and of course I
recognize that I would likely be worse
off in society if I were black then
being white Hispanic as I am and passing
as white I see color and that allows me
to recognize that if someone says you
could snap a finger and be black do you
want to do it no I'd be worse off in
society if I did that I recognize that
in part because I see color we also all
see color by the way by virtue of seeing
how different people are treated in
society by different institutions and
we're of course seeing that very much
with the George Floyd situation so I
think that that just about covers it
I find the phrase I don't see color to
be to be pretty silly quite frankly and
for people who are trying to make the
case that they're not making judgments
about others on the basis of race that I
like it may be true it may not be true
it's certainly something to aspire to
but let's be more accurate when we talk
about it we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p i'm
playing this voicemail for two reasons
number one as i mentioned earlier in the
show all of our protests and george
floyd coverage is being demonetised on
youtube and facebook so the fact that
someone called in and actually praised
our coverage really means a lot and
number two it has been really
heartwarming to see the number of people
reaching out to me and saying david I
really appreciate your coverage of the
protests you're not creating these false
black white hot takes you're actually
dealing with the complex nature of
what's going on here's one voicemail
caller who made a similar point david
wonder is why i'm happy to be a
subscriber of yours is that you're
probably the best progressive
commentator out there you're not
delusional you're not crazy and you
honestly try to precise the news from an
honest and fact-based perspective and
thanks for covering the george floyd
story very well and pointing out that
this is a story of many stories and not
just one thing that you need to focus on
there's so many problems in this country
that this is revealing thanks for being
a good reporter i I so appreciate that
and thanks to everybody who has been
writing in about about our coverage
we've got a great bonus show for you
today don't miss it get a membership at
join pakman.com to get instant access to
the bonus show I will see you then
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video